il a fallu 20 ans travaille 10 milliards
de dollars et l'apport de chercheurs
américains canadiens et européens
mais le grand télescope spatial james
webb devrait bientôt s'envoler à partir
du centre spatial européen en guyane
française
ce sera le nouveau diamant de
l'astrophysique une machine extrêmement
raffiné et ultra performante jamais on
rencontre un télescope aussi aussi grand
aussi puissant dans l'espace et pro
canada ces centres de barrio jamais dans
toute l'histoire du programme spatial
canadien at on été impliqués dans une
mission d'une telle envergure les
attentes sont élevées avec son miroir de
6 mètres 50 et ses instruments de pointe
le nouveau télescope est 100 fois plus +
5 le célèbre robot je ne jouais pas le
potentiel de frapper l'imaginaire
collectif autant club
alors qu a beau se concentre sur la
détection de la lumière visible le james
webb s'intéressent seulement au
rayonnement infrarouge est visible à
l'oeil nu la détection infrarouge permet
au télescope de voir à travers les
nuages de pousser à galactique et
d'étudier des phénomènes très froid et
très éloigné nous par exemple de
minuscules exoplanètes ce que ne peut
pas faire
on aura beau le plus grand au monde dans
le visible audrey à rien elles sont dans
les forêts c'est pourquoi on a dû
construire un télescope infrarouge le
james webb transporte trois instruments
scientifiques
le canada a conçu l'un d'entre eux le
liris mais également le système de
guidage qui va permettre au télescope de
pointer et de suivre ses cibles dans
l'immensité du ciel ce système là une
super précision parle environ 1
millionième de degré pour vous donner
une idée c'est à peu près l'épaisseur
d'un cheveu humain même un cheveux de
bébé à distance d'un kilomètre
donc on va être capable de pointer avec
ce genre de précisions là la principale
mission du jane's web c'est de
recueillir la lumière la plus ancienne
possible celle produite par les toutes
premières étoiles et galaxies qui sont
formés après le big bang l'univers est
âgée de 13 points 5 milliard d'années on
sait maintenant très précisément et on
sait que les premières galaxies se font
mais quelques centaines de millions
d'années donc on va regarder jusqu'à 13
points 5 milliards d'années de la terre
c'est effectivement ce web est une
machine à remonter dans le temps le
télescope va également s'intéresser de
près aux exoplanètes potentiellement
porteuse de vie si on réussissait à
analyser la composition chimique des
atmosphères des exo planète est détectée
soit des milieux propices à la vie ou
des biomarqueurs qui seraient des traces
de vie ces classes prix nobel pour
fonctionner les instruments du jane's
web doivent se trouver dans un
environnement très sombre et extrêmement
froid tout près du zéro absolu
le télescope va donc être posté à un
million et demi de kilomètres de la
terre
dans six mois si tout va bien il va
recevoir et enregistré ce que les
astronomes appellent la première lumière
après ça tout est possible
historiquement lorsqu'on regarde les
grands télescopes commandant des
opérations soient source sauter au sol
dans l'espace on pose la question quelle
était la principale découverte que
c'était ce que plus on fait et la
réponse est dix ans après la réponse ne
s'est pas ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
n'avait pas prévu ici normand grondin
radio-canada à montréal
[Musique]